first the special councel released their
findings today about their look into my
handling of classified documents I was
pleased to see they reached the
conclusion I believed and knew all along
they would that there are no charges
should be brought in this
case as many of you know this was an
exhaustive investigation going back
literally more than 40 years 40 years
when I became a United States Senator
when I was a
kid I was a kid 29 years old special
Council acknowledge I cooperated
completely I did not throw up any
roadblocks I sought no delays in fact I
was so determined to give special
counsel what they needed I went forward
with a five hour in-person interview
over the two days of October the 9th 8th
and 9th last year even though Israel had
just been attacked by Hamas on the 7th I
was in the middle of handling an
international crisis but I was a
especially pleased to see the special
counsel make clear the Stark differences
between this case and Donald Trump as a
special Council wrote and I quote
several material distinctions between Mr
Trump's case and Mr Biden's are clear by
the way this a republican councel most
notably after given multiple chances
this is the continuation of the quote he
returned classified documents and
avoided to avoid and avoided prosecution
Mr Trump allegedly did the oppos
opposite this is continued to quote
according to the indictment he has not
only refused to return documents for
many months he also obstructed Justice
by enlisting others to destroy evidence
and then lie about it in contrast Mr
Biden turned in classified documents to
the National Archives the Department of
Justice consented to a search of
multiple locations including his homes
and sat for voluntary interview and in
other ways cooperated with the
investigation that that's the
distinction among
others bottom line is the special
counsel of my case decided against
moving forward with any charges this
matter is now
closed